a long time ago in a fabrication plant
far far away well actually it wasn't
that far away and it was in June of 2016
that AMD Dro drop dropped the rx480 code
named Polaris in a wild marketing
campaign evoking Revolution and for good
reason the 400 series performed really
well for the price although the flagship
480 was quickly overshadowed by nvidia's
1060 ha the dangers of shooting first
but after 10 months of reloading AMD is
finally ready to fire again with the
only question being what's in the
chamber fire power or fire poor
[Music]
the Phoenix oour is a full-sized
minimalistically designed keyboard
complete with Cherry MX switches and a
new white backlit variant check it out
at the link
below come on it's okay maybe it's not
funny but it's silly so let's get this
out of the way this is still
Polaris the same architecture AMD used
for their RX 400 series if you you were
waiting for amd's highly anticipated
Vega
gpus then you'll be disappointed but if
you were waiting for Polaris enhanced
with a more mature 14 NM finfet process
and Tighter voltage and frequency
regulation translating into better power
efficiency and higher clock speeds then
you and all the other holdouts with R9
285s or R9 380s should be as hell right
about now well hold on a second here
lonus is this just a shinier 480 why is
this even worth a video and where is
Vega great
question RX 570 and 580 then presumably
due to slumping rx480 4 gig sales amd's
Partners will be putting more emphasis
on the top tier 8 gig version this time
time around though that won't have much
of an impact on you the consumer and
pricing looks to be well basically the
same with rx570 coming in $10 cheaper on
average than the 480 that it replaces in
other news amd's slide deck also had
prominent mentions of both the
rx550 and RX 560 the former of which is
brand new silicon but we don't have have
those yet so all we can say for now is
that apparently the rx550 is better than
an integrated GPU at $80 and I would
sure as hell hope so and the 560 is a
460 but with a $10 price drop and since
enthusiasts were running around
unlocking extra compute units with bios
tricks AMD went ahead and enabled those
right out of the
factory and I guess there's some
software news as well as of the rx5 100
series launch amd's Radeon driver for
every card from 7,000 series onward
includes what they're calling Radeon
chill a configurable frame limiter that
improves thermals and power draw when
enabled you can specify a minimum in
maximum frame rate and Radeon chill will
keep your game running within that
window Esports titles for instance are
designed to be easy to run and for that
reason they're notorious for ultra high
frame rates that go Way Beyond what it
typical or even very high-end monitor
would be able to display so what this
translates to for users is lower noise
and more consistent performance without
adding any input leg and in some cases
they claim even improving it pretty cool
right yeah call me when it's in a
notebook you guys also a bigger
supported games list would be swell
though to amd's credit the big orts
titles are mostly covered here all right
then lonus enough stalling tell us how
the RX 580 and 570 perform you guys are
so demanding sometimes you know okay so
we tested our shiny new cards on both
our Intel test bench and our ryen AMD
test bench along with equivalent last
gen cards from both AMD and Nvidia now
since AMD doesn't have reference boards
for the 500 series they actually sent us
Factory overclocked cards to test so
shout out to asusan Nvidia Who provided
us with some Factory overclocked cards
for the green side to level the playing
field somewhat before you ask by the way
we did try overclocking these cards
further but neither of them achieved a
core overclock of more than 50 MHz over
what they already shipped with so then
as we can see in our performance testing
obvious things are indeed obvious in
fact we've got a measurable if not earth
chattering performance bump over the RX
400 series direct X12 and Vulcan both
show us a wider Improvement than
directx11 thanks to those apis more
efficient rendering pipelines that favor
amd's gcn architecture although again
the difference isn't that massive and
also of note here is the utter ly
uninteresting differences in performance
between the Cards across Intel and AMD
CPU platforms so sorry conspiracy
theorists but the rumors of nvidia's
drivers crippling rise in performance
seem to have been greatly
exaggerated so the tldr then is that in
a big
surprise to no one we're looking at a
higher clocked RX 480 and 470 for this
release AMD chose to iterate on their
existing Polaris architecture cards in
order to address some of their short
comings against nvidia's mid-range and
budget lineup have they achieved that
well as far as performance is concerned
yes yes they have when it comes to power
consumption the story does fall apart a
little bit particularly with the Factory
overclocked cards though it should be
noted that we didn't use Radeon chill
for our testing because it makes apples
to Apple's comparisons go
sour so then if you're an AMD fan
desperately waiting to upgrade your
high-end Hawaii or Fiji based GPU then
you get to keep waiting but if you're
more of a mid-range buyer who didn't mow
enough Lawns last summer for a 47 or a
480 then great news because you get a
little bit more for your money this year
so rock on you sexy gardening Beast
you so you heard from your nephew or
niece or whatever that a VPN is a good
idea and you go and you look into it and
you're like what DNS configuration port
forwarding are you kidding me tunnel
bear takes all that crap out of setting
up a VPN for personal use you download
tunnel bear it's available for p PC Mac
Android iOS they even have a Chrome
extension you press like one button and
boom your internet connection gets
encrypted with AES 256-bit encryption
and you appear to the websites and
services that you want to use online as
though you are some Anonymous person
from some other random country allowing
you to access services that maybe you
normally wouldn't be able to they've got
a top rated privacy policy and they do
not log your user activity and the best
part of all of this is you don't have to
take my word for it you can try it for
free with 500 megabytes of data and no
credit card required when you choose to
get a year of unlimited data you can
even save 10% too by going to Tunnel
bear.com
LTT so thanks for watching guys if this
video sucked you know what to do but if
it was awesome get subscribed hit the
like button or check out the link to
where to buy the stuff we featured in
the video description also down there is
our merch store which has cool shirts
like this one and our community Forum
which you should totally join